hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the video where i google
myself to see what the internet
has to say about my everyday lives or at
least what you guys want to know
so i'm going to do this in a few ways
i'm going to let google decide what to
autofill in the search for myself
and then i'm going to try to guide it a
little bit i don't know where it's going
to go with this but i'm going to assume
it's going to go somewhere bad
so let me just search up markiplier
just baseline oh ah ooh
so nice ooh cool goodness grievous
oh there's my search popularity over
time well it peaked there
so i think we can all agree that's when
i peaked and then i'm just
i'm basically operating in 50 value this
is pretty much what i expected it to be
but i want it to be a little something
more than this so let's let google
decide markiplier is
dead dead asian and short
markiplier is this the end what is that
is this the
end this is the end for all of
markiplier's hoonies
have i finally accomplished my goal of
bumping glorious sexicles
tune in right now to find out
[Music]
people think that i peaked with five
nights at freddy's no no i'd like to
think i peeked with huni
and i'm just waiting for the sequel to
come out so that i can
peak once more markiplier is dead
oh good markiplier is dead
100 proof you first want to start out by
heating up
[Music]
right okay markiplier is
asian in case you didn't know
yeah there i am yes i
am asian i am half korean it is uh
nice margaret introduces his extremely
asian looking
brother tom what the [ __ ] does that even
mean so
i have some proof that markiplier
is just a big act it's just a big shtick
he doesn't really care about his
followers it's a play
like like no shame at all he's purposely
trying to be funny and it doesn't work
because he just looks like a little
[ __ ]
he's just it's so sad to see how
pathetic he
is for money where he's all like oh i
gotta make a funny face yeah
huh he's just he makes me sick
i know this has to be a joke because
there's literally the top left in the
top tap
free porn sex tube merry christmas
a christmas uh christmas markiplier is
all
okay so i just wanted to say merry
christmas to all my fans out there
and a terrible [ __ ] christmas to
markiplier i hope he got
cole from santa claus this year and by
the way if you notice something
different i got a great awesome new
microphone that my mommy gave me
and it sounds fantastic
so yeah merry christmas my fans and [ __ ]
you markiplier fanboys and markiplier
this is the quality content i i want
more
all right markiplier is short oh am i
oh am i really hey
let's go with something a different
angle to this is
markiplier mary
jacksepticeye no thank you
how tall is markiplier 5 10.
hell yeah markiplier dad
oh there's my pictures of my dad
that's me and my brother oh look at us
oh
look at this we're so cute oh look at me
look at me oh my god
markiplier crying oh here we go
okay try not to cry challenge
markiplier version oh oh
great oh this is what we need oh this is
what we need
oh great look at this [ __ ] here i
know what this is this is from
my 20 000 fan uh
20 000 subscriber fan video and i just
was
bawling like a baby oh it was one of the
first times i cried on camera and it
wouldn't be the last
oh look at me oh and of course it was
bob and then again
just recently bob on the tour made me
[ __ ] cry on stage like that
[ __ ] he said that in no uncertain
terms he was just like
i know he doesn't need anything else to
inflate his ego
but he honestly and truly thanked me you
know
for bringing him on the tour and i was
just like
come on dude i'm i'm in front of people
yeah as if i haven't cried in front of
like
forever fan made subscriber milestone
video apparently this one has
over a thousand fans reacting to me
reacting to something or other
uh as with the six million oh i should
do another fan reaction video i know i
should
i'll cry like a [ __ ] i'll cry like a
[ __ ]
i cried so much more in this one than i
did in this one hey guys this is
a slightly different video than what
you're used to oh geez
that was uh i wonder if those honor of
those
have they actually made another one yeah
i don't think that this video has ever
come
out this is um it was originally
markiplier sings badly and now it's
friends always matter just to make it a
rebranding which is totally fine
um but then like this video was supposed
to be the 10 million
subscriber milestone but then it came
and went so fast
and the the video got so ambitious
that i i think it just became harder and
harder to manage
um and then there probably was like a
file loss or something but either way
if this video is still underway
like because if you guys haven't seen
the the the if you guys haven't seen the
video
and i know there are other reaction
compilations here was that ethan
the [ __ ]
didn't notice that before ethan you conk
i'm coming
i'm gonna punch you that's so nice oh
geez
oh yeah if this video
is still underway in any capacity
please let me see it i would love to see
it i would love to react to it
i would love to do another reaction
video
i don't even care if it's late i don't i
don't care if it's late
if it is that's fine i i i want to see
it i still want to see it
so please support markiplier friends
always matter
and uh yeah that'd be cool anyway back
to the whole reason i'm doing this with
google what's he [ __ ] markiplier this is
one video for [ __ ]
[ __ ] you
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you that's so shitty quality
too i love it [ __ ] you markiplier here
we go i'm ready hey multiplayer
stupid [ __ ] idiot i hear your stupid
[ __ ] mario games what's up mitsubis
how you doing today dudes
good so today i hate what's his name
again mom
i don't know michael you cannot be
offended people on the
video you see about that chinese yeah
michael you don't care because you're
doing bad videos too and nobody say
nothing
why ocidash is good barry you stupid
chinese guy
it's a if you know about the blue hair
because why the [ __ ]
well i'm trying to be crazy with the guy
look i can go crazy
[Music]
[Laughter]
good job
[Music]
[Laughter]
gonna get in trouble what's coming
[ __ ] like two hero songs that kid's
two years old
what's up what is it called [ __ ] you
markiplier
oh my god you see your stupid chinese
guy huh
i know your name come on keith do you
remember that name
kyla oh i'm i'm the stupid chinese guy
like my glasses if you know about that
guy read the comments below
it's called mark carla or something
you'll sing like this
this channel sucks it was like both the
funniest and the cringiest thing i've
ever seen in my
entire life i am subscribing oh that's
so funny
oh geez oh that's a nice one markiplier
fan art
oh that's so nice i've seen some of this
but i don't think i've seen
all of it oh that's a good one that's a
classic
that's the original piece of fan art
that is my channel icon
if you recognize that head that's what
my channel icon is and has been
for years oh
classic uh classic oh this stuff is good
oh this stuff is good this person wolf
jedi samuel i think i remember the name
is ooh
[ __ ] look at oh my god i've seen this
one before it's so cool
oh look at this handsome devil look a
handsome devil
oh my god look at that one look at this
one oh look at this one
oh it's a pinterest thing oh hello hi
look at that one oh
oh this is uh this is one of the ones
this is they didn't make this
stupid meme but you know they made uh
yeah that was made by the person that
also did the tour
poster art and did an amazing job at it
i i
uh it's um vicarano vicarano
vicarano yeah vicarano does
amazing work and uh she actually made
the tour
art oh my god oh i remember gremblo
oh man that was actually just recently
what am i remembering it was just just
happened
there is also i bet if we go over back a
few things
there's the markiplier fans deviantart
this has existed since
pretty much the beginning of my channel
and has been the one place to go
that i go to for fan art if you
have fan art that you want everyone or
me to see and you have a deviantart
hosted
here i also am reinvigorating my
subreddit if you want to go there
check that out post it up vote it i want
to see
all of it i want it and i want to start
putting into videos again because you
got like this timeline you can actually
go and see
all of it way back in the past what is
what is that
oh back in the pajama stream oh oh i
wish
oh i wish look at that bulge oh
[ __ ] oh my god oh yeah i are deadite
oh ir dead i was one of the first people
to like
really get into the darkiplier fan art
and oh my god
yeah i've seen so much of this stuff
oh they do such good work yeah but it's
just
it's really cool there's so much history
here there's so much fan arts that's
been posted
and you know it's something that i
really love good stuff good stuff good
stuff
markiplier x oh ho ho ho
that went down a rabbit hole real quick
i don't know what
lemon means but i'm i'm gonna i'm gonna
back off on that one markiplier means
exactly what everybody always wanted
yes
look at this meme guys
oh man oh i know right
so relatable
that's not it's not one of those
relatable memes i'm not
100 sure ah [ __ ] herb lore oh my god
herb
herb lore
[Music]
such a weird word herb lore herblore it
stops becoming a word
herb lore or blur herb
say it herblore say it herblore
herblore herb lore
herblore herb
morgiblier birthday that's
it that's my birthday and that
is a good one to end on so thank you
everybody who has joined me thus far on
my birthday
i don't know if it's going to be posted
on the same day or a different day but
thank you for watching as i google
myself
the answer is no ah anyway so that was
fun i googled myself go google yourself
maybe you'll find something interesting
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you thought
down in the comments below
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye